Well, we got a little baby naming drama
I want your take on.
The Sun reports a woman in the UK
posted this dilemma online.
She and her husband, they're about to have a little baby.
And they finally, after discussing it,
they finally picked out a name, Miles,
which is such a cute name.
The only problem is when she told her best friend,
the best friend totally gasped (gasps)
because Miles is the name
that she had picked out for her future son.
Now, her friend is not pregnant right now though,
but she plans one day she wants to have a baby.
But she seemed genuinely disappointed that, you know,
her friend had snatched the name.
So this woman wanted to know,
should she feel guilty right now
for planning to name her son Miles,
or should she just go like forward with it?
I have a strong opinion, but I'm curious what you-
I have some really strong opinions.
Ooh.
Audience, guests, raise your hand
if you think she should go with the name.
Raise your hand
if you think she shouldn't name her son Miles
because her friend likes it.
Nobody, okay.
Oh, all right.
Well.
All right,
so I think this is a one-way street here.
Yeah, well what about you? What do you think?
No!
She shouldn't back off.
She should just stick with Miles, no matter her friend says?
Yes, you're not even pregnant!
And how about instead of making my big moment not about you.
Why couldn't they both be Miles?
Do you guys remember in like elementary school?
I had so many Jennifers in my class.
There was like Jennifer W, Jennifer D, Jennifer C.
I still have one of them saved as Jennifer C in my phone.
Like, and we all were fine. So there can be two Miles.
Chill out, girl. Plus, you don't have a baby yet.
Right?
(Drew sighs)
I know.
All right, and finally,
a pic from "Drew's Little Yellow Book."
It's a little yellow book that I curate every week
for you, because I love to share.
And this week is very important.
Today kicks off Black History Month and we are celebrating
with putting the spotlight on Gyrl Wonder.
They are a nonprofit doing incredible work
to support young women of color
reaching for the careers of their dreams,
and their extensive mentorship program
pairs young women with professionals
for special one-on-one tutelage and relationships.
And we're donating $1,000
to that incredible team at Gyrl Wonder to support you
and thank you for all that you do.
To find out more about them and how you can get involved,
please go to our website at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
or the little yellow book.
(bright music)